we have a vaccine for the coronavirus
and now
all we need to do is figure out who gets
the vaccine should be pretty easy right
because we know that
old older people are more vulnerable to
the virus
younger people basically don't have much
risk of death for the virus so you just
give it to them based on age
no the new york times has a different
idea
in an article titled the elderly versus
essential workers
who should get the coronavirus vaccine
first the
the new york times's brilliant idea
backed up by public health experts
is uh to give it to non-white people
uh rather than white people because the
white people don't deserve the vaccine i
kid
you not this from mark lip
lipsich an infectious disease
epidemiologist at harvard
says a teachers should not be considered
essential workers
if the goal of the committee is to
reduce health inequities
a quote teachers have middle class
salaries are
very often white and they have college
degrees
you know they should be treated good and
everything but you know not like other
other workers
you know they're white they don't they
don't deserve to live uh
next one from what's this guy's name
from harold schmidt an expert in ethics
ethics and health policy at the
university of pennsylvania
says that it is reasonable to put
essential workers ahead of older adults
because not because the workers are
essential not because the jobs they're
doing are so essential
which is a morally dubious question at
best
but because quote older populations are
whiter
society is structured in a way that
enables them to live
longer instead of giving additional
health benefits to those who already had
more of them
we can start to level the playing field
a bit
so how do we determine who gets the
coronavirus vaccine
we need to kill all the white people
according to the left
the the time for unity and healing
involves
killing off disfavored races and the
craziest part of it is
it's not just the new york times that
thinks that it's not just radical
leftists in the media
that is the argument coming straight out
of the cdc
welcome to the new american caste system
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday from jimmy hartman
who says this is the proper response to
eternal lockdowns
one don't close your business two don't
wear a mask
three don't pay the fine four do not
live in fear
completely right the the only qualifier
i'll put on that is
if you have to live in fear at all it
will be in fear of the government
forcing these stupid things on you
because
99.7 chance you're going to be fine
if you get the coronavirus but you have
a much
lower chance of being okay if the
government comes after you
for not submitting to their capricious
rules rand paul had a great
medical scientific and political
discussion of these masks over the
weekend
you know we will we will remember back
to those halcyon days of
10 or 11 months ago before we all had to
cover up our faces in public and rarely
go into public because we're locked up
in our homes
15 days to slow the spread the longest
15 days of my entire life
can you even remember all that way back
well if you want to remember those
wonderful memories you should get a
legacy box
legacy box is an effortless way to have
your aging tapes
films and photos digitally preserved in
a modern format
so that they are safe for generations so
many of us have these irreplaceable
moments
on tapes and film reels that we can no
longer
watch your home movies have become like
a time capsule
legacy box can help you open it restore
all those important moments keep them
organized and safe for the future
because they will deteriorate
if you keep them on those old media i
tell you this it's very sad to me
a beloved family member who died
i i just had all the physical photos i
lost them and this was before i had
legacy box the first thing i did
when legacy when i learned about legacy
bucks i sent them in mailed them in i
got
my physical media back i got them
digitized i can have those memories
forever right now legacy box is offering
50 off so you can have everything
preserved at once for a fraction of the
regular price
once you have these digital versions you
can relax knowing
that they will be secure for generations
it's last minute i know but you can
still get the most meaningful gift
for christmas head on over right now
legacybox.com
knowles take advantage of this limited
time offer 50 off
uh then use their kit send it in
whenever you're ready legacy box dot com
slash knowles
know wlas save 50 while supplies
last i'm looking
at my hands and my arm i don't know if
i'm entitled to get the coronavirus
vaccine i
i think i'm technically white i because
of my southern italian ancestry
sicilian i am a little swarthier you
know maybe this will bump me a little
further up the line
to get the vaccine because the vaccine
is not going to be
given out based on your age it's not
going to be given out based on your risk
factors for catching this virus it's not
even going to be given out based on your
professional risk factors it's going to
be given out
whether you're in a favored race or a
disfavored race
and according to the new york times if
you're white
according to these public health experts
at harvard and all of these elite
institutions
if you're white you don't deserve the
vaccine and the premise here is that
you're all
we're all going to die from coronavirus
it's so super duper dangerous that you
got to lock yourself in your room we
have to wait for the vaccine
so what they are saying the the experts
and the media
they're saying that if you're white you
deserve to die
you don't you don't be because of
historical injustice that's the
catch-all phrase
you don't deserve to have this
life-saving
vaccine i have questions about how
deadly the virus really is we were told
initially that you know this was
extraordinarily deadly then we have
studies that show
99.7 percent survival rate so got
questions about that got some questions
about the vaccine
but nonetheless according to their
premise that is
the new american caste system and the
cdc is backing it up
according to the daily mail the cdc has
quote advised states to consider ethnic
minorities as a critical and vulnerable
group in their vaccine distribution
plans this is already in effect half of
the nation states
have have plans that prioritize black
hispanic and indigenous residents over
white people in some way
as the vaccine rolls out according to
the
daily mails analysis 25 states have
committed to focus
on racial and ethnic communities but
only obviously
not all everyone has a race everyone has
an ethnicity so only
some favored racial and ethnic
communities as they decide which groups
should be prioritized
in receiving a coronavirus vaccine dose
this is
absolutely disgusting this is against
the law this is criminal
the people who are putting this into
effect should be brought up on charges
for it it's
absolutely outrageous they won't be
because
no matter how much you hear the left
talk about
color blindness racial justice racial
equality
they don't want that at all what they
want
is a sort of inv what you would call
inverted racism it's just racism it's
just bigotry
that disfavors white people and asian
people who now by the way for
uh many institutions are being counted
as white people i don't know how they
they had that unfavorable title voiced
upon them but that's where we stand
and they would favor other races now
this is so disgusting
this is so vile and anti-american that
the cdc is walking this back
so after the hubbub over all of this
they said that okay now americans over
75
should be able to get the vaccine along
with the essential frontline workers
and the favored races which is an
improvement i suppose but it's still not
enough we know that people who are 65 to
75
are at a higher risk than frontline
workers generally
but if you're 65 to 75 and you're white
then you're you're not permitted to get
it according to these reports according
to the cdc
does not fully address the issue now
it's very easy to say that this is
hypocrisy right and i think most of the
conservative criticism of these
disgusting policies
is that it's hypocrisy it's actually not
hypocrisy
to use a phrase from the great harvard
law professor adrian vermeuel
when the left does all these kinds of
crazy things
it's not hypocrisy it's hierarchy
the left you know we always talk about
well the tolerant left or well you know
the race blind left or whatever
when i listen to leftists today
they don't really talk about tolerance
all the time at least not in the way we
understand it they're not really talking
about racial equality in the way that
conservatives would talk about it
they are actively coming out and saying
no we need to
prioritize certain favored groups over
other favored groups
we don't want equality we don't want
fairness we want
a kind of reverse caste system
for the alleged historical injustices
that's that isn't hypocrisy to give the
devils their due
to give the leftists their due they are
explicitly saying yeah white people have
had too many advantages
so now we're going to give them
disadvantages even if that means that
you've got this vaccine that we're all
telling you is very very important to
get
well you're not getting it too bad
that's because of your
race now the cdc is walking this back
because it's just too far
even for for where the country is right
now but all it is doing is testing the
limits of ideology
right all it's doing is seeing how far
can we push
our racial grievance sort of politics i
was
over the weekend i was at tpusa it was i
think the largest
not just the largest conservative
gathering in america there were about
1600 2000 students there in the room
this is the largest gathering on earth
right now they are standing a thwart
these
lockdowns and yelling stop but
we were we were discussing kind of
the how far this sort of thing is going
to go and it's they're they're going to
keep pushing and pushing this idea
until someone says stop you always hear
about uh questions of reparations or
racial
justice or whatever how can we finally
correct the wrongs of the past
first of all you can never write the
wrongs of the past because they go all
the way back to the garden of eden
but second of all let's just say you
could let's say we have a reparations
program
and you could figure out exactly who
deserves to get the money and exactly
who deserves to pay the money
which is virtually impossible but just
for the sake of argument let's go with
it
and you you could arrange this and then
that will correct the
the racial injustices okay fine give me
a number
give me a number what's the amount of
money i'll pay it
assuming i can pay if we can that solves
all the problems once and for all great
give me a number i'll write a check
and give me a date give me an end date
because i want to know
if we're going to correct the injustice
by forcing certain groups to pay more
and other groups to do to
have fewer rights and what okay fine
give me the end date and the amount of
money and then we'll solve it and then
we can move on and we'll all be happy
right
there is no end date there is no amount
of money it's a lie
it's a total lie to create a new
hierarchy conservatives don't want there
to be a racial hierarchy
right we want to say yes we're all
americans we're all going to
the left is uh has a different idea
now i'm not too worried about the
vaccine thing because i don't intend to
get the vaccine because i'm a young
healthy person and i don't see any
reason that i should
i think most of the experts feel this
way too the only people i think who
believe
in these kind of the necessity of these
lockdowns and canceling christmas and
canceling thanksgiving
and not seeing your family i think the
only people who believe that
are gullible liberals the experts
themselves
are flouting their own rules we saw it
with pelosi we saw it with fauci we saw
it with
gavin newsom we saw it with cuomo we saw
it with the other cuomo we saw it with
everyone in our public health sector on
the political side and on the scientific
side
and now i'm sorry to say
it's even come down to dr scarf dr
deborah burks
she was considered the slightly better
version of anthony fauci
turns out dr scarf has
been flouting her own rules i thought
she was the one public health expert
that we could maybe rely on you know i
was but she was the one who was really
just dedicated
to serious thought not to these kind of
political
games unfortunately that's not not the
case not
not much of a pure thinker if you want
to be a thinker though you got to check
out thinker
in our fast-paced world you know it's
very difficult to make
reading a priority at least it used to
be at thinkor.org
they summarize the key ideas from new
and noteworthy non-fiction
they give you access to an entire
library of great books in bite-sized
form you can read
or listen to hundreds of titles in a
matter of minutes from old classics
like dale carnegie's how to win friends
and influence people to recent
bestsellers like jordan peterson's 12
rules for life
thinker offers a huge variety of titles
from across
a ton of different categories current
affairs politics business education
history relationships you'll even find
titles from our very own
ben shapiro right side of history or
mount walsh the unholy trinity
but it doesn't just stop there maybe
they'll have my
book with words when it comes out which
won't be too long from now
it's very tough you know in in this time
to make uh
the free time to read but you really
have to
one because you want to challenge your
preconceptions two because you want to
expand your horizons
and three this is most important because
you want to sound smart at cocktail
parties go to thinkor
t-h-i-n-k-r-dot-org no e no time for
that
start a free trial and download the app
today let them know
that you heard about them on the michael
knowles show that is thinker.org
so right before thanksgiving dr scarf
warned americans to be vigilant
limit celebrations to your immediate
household
then the day after thanksgiving do you
know what dr scarf did
she went to her home on fenwick island
in delaware
and she didn't go alone she was
accompanied by three
generations of the scarf family
it was dr burks her husband
a daughter son-in-law two grandchildren
all present
there are lockdown rules for thee but
not for me that is how all of these guys
have been treating it
and when dr scarf was called out for
this she responded
i can't this is the perfect response she
goes i did not go to delaware for the
purpose of celebrating thanksgiving
yeah you went for the purpose of
celebrating the day after thanksgiving
as if
thanksgiving day that's the only day
that the virus is dangerous
because the virus not only can it
discern between political ideologies
not only does it know not to infect
people at blm rallies but
definitely to infect people at
anti-lockdown conservative rallies
not only does it know not to affect
people at left-wing riots but definitely
to infect people
at churches but moreover
it knows thanksgiving day that's when
we're going to infect everybody but day
after thanksgiving look the
the virus just like all of us it's full
it's stuffed it doesn't it doesn't need
anymore
that was the first part of her excuse
the second part
this was perfect i didn't even know this
was a verb she said
she had to go up there she had to go to
her house
to winterize the property
you know you we all need to go winterize
our vacation homes don't we
what are you gonna you're gonna allow
your your vacation home to be summarized
during the winter
oh my gosh could you imagine how
humiliating that would be wouldn't you
feel the fool
if you had summarized your home in
winter and you can't go winterize your
vacation home
alone no no no what you're going to go
winterize your home and then not have
an elaborate feast with your family no
please
this is this is a civilized country i
don't care if we're in the middle of a
pandemic
can't ask we can ask people to give up
their jobs and their loved ones funerals
and all of their holidays and their
livelihoods and
their life savings we can they can give
that up but they can't give up
winterizing their second home
pretty pathetic stuff i wish she had
just come out and said
sorry whoops you caught me
i obviously i'm not worried about the
virus none of us are worried about the
virus
we wash our hands or whatever but you
know it's an epidemic it's going to
spread anyway
it's fine live your life don't imprison
yourself for
more than a year we're not doing it you
shouldn't do it either no
because this is all about power
and you're seeing this on the vaccine it
occurred to me
conservatives are all being shamed
yelled at you know you need to wear the
mask you need to
lock down you can't see your friends you
can't see your family
you need to get the vaccine but then the
minute conservatives do get the vaccine
we're told you shouldn't get the vaccine
because of these new crazy racial
hierarchies
and actually it's it goes even beyond
race it goes to
ideology if you really look into it
marco rubio
down in florida gets the vaccine
takes a big picture of it this is part
of a public health campaign members of
congress have been cleared to have the
vaccine
as a matter of both national security
because they're you know elected
officials
but also to encourage other people who
are skeptical of the vaccine to go get
it it's all going to be fine right
so rubio does this he follows the rules
and goes and does this
and he's being criticized dr jeremy
faust who's some blue check mark on
twitter
he says i'm an er doctor and despite
trying
i have not been able to get the vaccine
oh that's too bad yeah i guess i guess
the er doctor should get it before the
senator maybe i don't know
i see there's an argument there i guess
anna navarro that fake republican who
goes on television on all the left-wing
channels
she tweets out she was more scathing she
says young healthy senator who spoke at
rallies packed with thousands without
masks
who supports trump who's downplayed
kovit and mocked those who wear masks
is the first to get the vaccine while
most medical workers elderly and
infirm americans wait congratulations on
your privilege marco rubio
now me i don't intend to get the vaccine
not be
i've had i've had other vaccines but i
just i'm probably not going to get this
one because i don't think i need it
because statistically i have a very low
risk of dying from this virus
it's possible that i could but
everything about life involves risk i
could walk out right now
and get hit by a car and so i just i
don't really i don't get flu shots
either i'm just not too worried when i'm
when i'm more elderly and frail i will
get them now i don't i'm pleased to know
though
that i will be lauded for my great
nobility that i'm leaving more vaccines
for the people who need them much more
than i do
i'm so i'm so happy that my choice my
very likely choice not to get the
vaccine
will be perceived as virtuous but of
course it won't
right it's just any anything
conservatives do with regard to this
virus
whether you lock down whether you go out
whether you get the vaccine whether you
don't get the vaccine
anything you do will be called wrong and
evil and terrible and you're a murderer
and there's a double standard it would
appear for millennial politicians
because at the same time rubio's posting
his little picture aoc
is posting video after video of her
getting the vaccine talking about the
vaccine there she is she's got her
shoulder exposed doctor
pushing in the syringe
aoc i assume she's smiling i can't tell
because she's wearing that mask
okay all right that's it yeah yeah
good hooray she's being applauded that's
so wonderful
not good when rubio does it but great
when she does it
this is also not hypocrisy this is not
hypocrisy this is
hierarchy you actually you heard the cdc
in the new york times say it
that you you we need to prioritize
members of certain races so you can say
okay aoc
is a i don't know the proper term now is
it hispanic is it latino i
saw someone's because it's la tinx i
don't know whatever it is
she's a member of this particular race
that is supposed to get the vaccine
before everyone else
and rubio's a white guy right well no i
guess rubio is a hispanic guy
but then if you read further into the
left sort of perverse views on race
you'll remember hannah nicole jones the
1619 project lady
who came out just a couple of months ago
and said there's a difference between
being physically
one race and politically that race this
was in response when joe biden said if
you're not voting for me you ain't black
and she defended him she came out and
she said look there's a difference
between being physically black like
clarence thomas
and politically black like malcolm x
right according to these people i'm just
using their own words this is not my
fevered interpretation of what they're
saying according to these people
marco rubio he really isn't hispanic
clarence thomas he really isn't black
they might look that way but they're not
really
because they're conservative and if you
don't go along with the leftist agenda
you are not really that race all of
these
sort of shortcuts you know they focus on
race a lot but whether it's sex or
sexual desire or whatever they're
they're always kind of
circling back around to this ideology
that
is not necessarily hypocrisy
because they are open about it it's just
hierarchy what this is all about
is power what this is all about to use
rand paul's words he just gave this
yesterday at tpusa i didn't i
actually didn't run into him there but
uh we probably missed each other by
a couple hours he had a great line which
is that these lockdowns and these masks
are not about medicine
they're not about ideology they're not
about science
the way the vaccine is going to be
rolled out what it's all about
is submission it'd be one thing if we
were told
you have to give up your liberty you
have to give it your freedom we're going
to save your life
but what if you have to give up all your
freedoms and they're wrong on the
science
every one of the mandates and you look
in country after country state after
state you look at when the mass
mandates went in the incidents went up
exponentially after the mandates
restaurants nobody can eat in a
restaurant there's no science behind any
of
that
middle seat missing on the airplane you
really think you're like 12 inches from
the other guy
instead of six inches it really makes a
difference none of it really makes
any sense and there's no epidemiological
evidence you know it's like
wash your hands stand six feet apart
there's no evidence that that slowed
down the
i think that the trajectory of the the
virus has been
it hasn't been altered at all by any of
these things
hasn't been altered at all if only
somebody
had been saying that from the beginning
oh yeah well it's not just me it's all
the conservatives have been saying this
from the very beginning now rand paul
not just an expert on politics u.s
senator he's also an expert scientist
right he is a
medical doctor he practices medicine he
understands
science he will be written off he's not
a real expert he's not a real doctor
he's not a real politician he's not
because he's on the wrong side of it
but the point he's making is absolutely
true this is capricious
this has nothing to do with science the
way that the cdc is talking about i mean
it's so offensive to people of all races
i think
to say only this special race gets the
virus it gets the vaccine
and this special race this unspecial
race rather
does not get the vaccine that's so
offensive to everybody
regardless of that which race gets it
whatever
we all have to acknowledge that's not
scientific it's being gussied up in the
language of science they say
well certain races because they work
certain jobs more likely or they live in
certain neighborhoods more likely
or they have certain income more likely
therefore they're at greater risk and
therefore we need to use race as a
shortcut to get the vaccine
they're gussying it up in the language
of science which the left always does
you see this most notably on on
environmentalism because they'll say
for 100 years the left has wanted what
universal
socialized health care they've wanted
massive wealth redistribution
they've wanted uh much more government
control they wanted a big expansion of
the bureaucracy they wanted to give up
some national sovereignty to
transnational institutions
and so in the 70s they said we have to
do all these things because of
overpopulation
and it turned out overpopulation was
complete bs they said there are going to
be famines if we don't do this
inevitable it's going to happen
world population doubles we're all
fatter than ever then they said it's
global cooling
we're heading to a new ice age so we got
to do all the stuff we want and then
global cooling turned out to be bunk and
they said no it's actually it's global
warming
and so but we still need all the exact
same solutions that coincidentally we've
wanted politically for 100 years
then global warming stops for a little
while they say okay no it's
it's climate change you know because it
was sunny yesterday and now it's
foggy so you anyway you still got to
give us the exact
same answers okay you can gussy anything
up in this
silly jargon and pretend that it's
scientific and therefore outside the
realm of debate
but it ain't it's all politics you want
to see the
the great a basement of of science
is we've now got dr fauci now he's not
only playing the politician he's also
playing an entertainer
on television you know when i think
of people that i could see this this
christmas
i i know that we're not supposed to see
anybody but you know who's going to come
knocking on my door could be a delivery
man
it could be my mother-in-law the worst
one that it could be
dr fauci uh he was one he i would not
answer the door if dr fatchi rang my
belt
that's why i'm so glad that we have ring
ring
you know it's doorbell season okay it's
the busiest time of the year at your
front door
you're going to want to know who's at
your house you're going to want to keep
an eye on the hustle and bustle
no matter where you are right from your
phone this weekend i flew out i was in
georgia i was in florida
i was all over the place if somebody
stops why i'm going to want to know
who's at that door sweet little alisa is
a very good shot
you know because she just keeps blasting
and blasting and blasting but look i
don't i don't want to have to fix my
door or anything like that
i want my sweet little alisa to be able
to see who's outside the door
before she opens the door this holiday
season it's not just the best time to
have a ring
it is the best time to give it to
it's a little secret i hope none of the
friends i've given it to are listening
right now
the reason i give ring out is a
housewarming gift to my friends
not just because it's terrific not just
because it makes you feel like you're
living in the future it's because it's
not that expensive it's but it seems
very expensive
great time to give the gift for a
limited time go to ring.com
knowles kwles for special holiday offers
that is
ring dot com slash knowles can w
l e s now
we've got to take a quick break you know
we've got a lot of fun stuff coming up
in this new year
one thing we've got is the historical
docu-series apollo 11 what we saw
now available exclusively for daily wire
members apollo 11 what we saw is
available to watch as well as listen
over at dailywire.com
make sure to get our apple tv or roku
apps to get all of our content on the
big screen like tonight's
christmas edition of backstage
dailywire.com
subscribe get 20 off your membership
with code watch and access all of our
new and existing content
go to dailywire.com we'll be right back
with a lot more
you want to see what a farce the
scientific establishment has become
now that they've become themselves
getting into the
scientific racism or this sort of
getting into these kind of caste system
developments but we've got the exalted
dr fauci our most powerful politician
in the country and therefore the world
going on television and doing a little
soft shoe playing the entertainer and
joking
about santa claus to allay all the fears
that they've all instilled in the
children
and elmo's back for something else that
i think is on a lot of kids minds
elma's friend has a question about santa
claus
how did santa get the vaccine
and is it safe for him to go in the
house how can
santa claus safely give out presents
with covid 19 spreading everywhere
how can he do it will santa still be
able to
visit me in corona viruses season
but if he can't go to anyone's house
or near his reindeer
well i have to say i took care of that
for you because i was worried that you'd
all be upset
so what i did a little while ago i took
a trip up there to the north pole
i went there and i vaccinated santa
claus myself
i measured his level of immunity and he
is good to go
he can come down the chimney he can
leave the presence
he can leave and you have nothing to
worry about
santa claus is good to go it's going to
be so sad
when santa claus has complications from
this thing and then dr fauci will have
killed jolly old saint nicholas that
will be so
that'll be like the worst thing fouchy
ever did but probably that won't happen
right probably
santa claus will be totally fine he'll
have the vaccine that'll that'll be all
good
except i was just told
by dr fauci that even after you get the
vaccine
you are not supposed to travel you are
still supposed to wear the mask all the
time
you are not allowed to go out and live
your life so
one day fauci no maybe it's just maybe
it's just hierarchy maybe
i have to play by a certain set of rules
but jolly old saint nicholas
does not this is very silly stuff
and it shows you by the way how
unserious it all is
when fauci and berks and cuomo and
pelosi
and newsom and the one in chicago what's
her name lori lightfoot and the one in
dc
what's her name uh i don't even remember
the mayor of dc
and the one in new york de blasio and
all these different people
when they violate their own rules you
can tell they're being unserious
about the the lockdown measures
but when they make little jokes about it
like this you can tell they're being
unserious too
they go on oh yeah no we said all you
have to get the vaccine but hey
santa claus will be fine no don't worry
kids just
just do whatever we say we want to allay
your fears
also by the way what they are doing to
children right now with this virus
is abusive they are robbing children
of much of their childhood right they're
robbing them
of some of the most what could be the
most joyous years of their life right
you just get to go outside and play
be in school see your friends that's
gone because of this
ridiculous political exercise but also
they're really terrifying these kids see
rates of anxiety are already going up in
children now for the past couple years
because of their parents neuroses and
now these children are terrified because
of a virus
where it is statistically impossible to
kill them
the odds of a child dying from
coronavirus
are so infinitesimally small that
these children should be more afraid of
the boogeyman hiding in their closet
and yet they are afraid and of course
they are afraid because of these
fear-mongering
cynics and scoundrels in the public
health establishment
and in the media and in elective office
who are using this virus as an
opportunity
for social engineering they said it the
new york times said it
in their ridiculous racist article and
the cdc and the ridiculous
racist guidelines they're saying this is
really an opportunity
to you know fix some inequities fix some
historical injustices
what does that mean oh you mean it's not
you're going to exploit a pandemic
to push your own perverse
racial policies very very
and you know by the way there are actual
problems in the country i know because
we've turned
this uh particular pandemic
into the the worst crisis that america's
ever faced
that we've forgotten we have other
problems right now in san francisco
many multiples more people are dying
from drug overdoses than are dying from
coronavirus
621 people have died in san francisco
from drug overdoses this year
compared to 173 people who've died from
coronavirus and by the way we know that
the coronavirus numbers are inflated
that that's not some wild crazy theory
we know it because
the county coroners and health officials
have pointed out that people who are
dying from gunshots
are being counted as covid deaths we
don't know the extent of the over
counting but there certainly is over
counting going on
because any person who dies with the
coronavirus is said to have died
from the coronavirus we don't know it
could be a very small number it could be
a huge number
but here's what we do know regardless of
what
how reliable that number is many
multiples more people are dying from
drugs
in in san francisco that's considered
fine
according to the new standards we should
legalize all drugs
it's a personal choice it's a matter of
personal freedom you have a right darn
it
a natural right to kill yourself with
drugs
i don't think that's true but
that is the new standard we're living
under and even many conservatives go
along with that i know so many
conservatives
who say uh the war on drugs failed i
don't even know what that statement
means
we put a lot of drug dealers in prison
doesn't sound like that failed to me
sounds like it worked pretty well
well people still do drugs yeah of
course they do people are still gonna
we have a laws against murder people are
still gonna commit murders the point is
you wanna
punish these things and try to control
these things
but that system has been flipped
including on murder by the way
la and this is shocking even to me i
know how left-wing
la gets but the la district attorney
already was a huge liberal and that lada
lost to an even more radical person
george gascon i don't even know how to
pronounce his name
who is running on a platform and who won
on a platform basically of springing
some of the worst prisoners from the
clink so
he recently was approached while he was
giving a little talk he was approached
by the mother of joshua rodriguez
who was kidnapped tortured and murdered
in 2015.
and recently special circumstances were
filed on the accused killers
those will be dropped under gascon's new
policy
which will take life without parole
off the table so the killers will not
seriously be punished
for what they did and this mother walks
up to this new d.a and starts pleading
with him yelling at him
listen to the arrogance listen to the
contempt
in this jerk's voice i apologize you
know it's unfortunate that we have
people that do not have enough education
to keep their vaults out for a woman so
we can talk
but anyway my son would never speak
again because he was murdered
he was kidnapped tortured and murdered
to communicate with you
my son matters
killed my son tortured him
what are you gonna do about it
[Music]
he's just walking away he's just he
doesn't need to hear this what does he
care
this guy gascon is cartoonishly
villainous
can you imagine a grieving mother saying
these people
murdered my son and you're gonna let
them get off the hook basically or
you're gonna let them
have a much less severe punishment and
he turns to her
with pure disdain and he says i'm sorry
that some people are not
educated enough to keep to no one to
keep their mouth shut
so that i can talk this guy is
particularly
visibly villainous this is how
every single one of these establishment
elites
thinks about the rest of their
countrymen they might not say it they
might have
slightly better political sense than to
say that
but that is what they think i think
why are these little plebeians why are
they
oh your murdered son oh what you think
you should be
the killer should be punished you just
don't have as brilliant and broad a mind
as i have
to understand that actually the killers
they're victims of a
system and you just don't you're too
you're too close you're too emotional
you frivolous woman you're not educated
like me
you i don't care about your pleading
that's what they think that's what
they've thought about us from the
beginning by the way
with this lockdown isn't it we say you
know
our family members are dying alone for
absolutely no reason we're not allowed
to have funerals we
haven't been able to see them we can't
live you've taken our livelihoods from
us you've taken our life savings from us
you won't give us any even any sort of
stimulus not any significant stimulus
to stay afloat we're losing everything
over here and what do the public health
experts say they basically say
gosh some people are not educated enough
to know when to keep their mouth shuts
and let dr fauci talk or dr
scarf talk even though we don't believe
what we're saying we don't believe it
for us
but we believe it for you you all need
to stay locked down and lose your
livelihoods
so that you know we're going to commute
on zoom we're going to go to our beach
houses
no big deal that's a hierarchy
dr scarf and dr fauci and pelosi and
gavin newsom at the french laundry and
cuomo and all these guys they get to do
things that the rest of americans don't
get to do
because they're in a special privileged
class and
according to the left there ought to be
special privileged classes
and if you're a member of a special
privileged class you get you get to go
to the beach house and you get to have
thanksgiving
and you get the vaccine first and
that's it because you deserve it and you
you know they'll just pay lip service to
historical injustice oppression
uh i don't know whatever the buzzword is
that's intersectionality that
and that's why there's really no
argument there
it's because they're in the class and
you're not in the class i'll give you a
really great example of this
uh i think it was a week ago or so the
proud boys you know the proud boys
they're
sort of raucous group on the right
and there there have been members of the
proud boys by the way who are pretty
extreme so i'm not i'm not saying
all totally defensible i think that the
leader of the prat boys has been
unfairly
targeted as a white supremacist and my
evidence that he's unfairly targeted
as a white supremacist is that he's a
black hispanic guy
but he's not no he's not though actually
according to the left
even though he is black and hispanic his
name is enrique torrio
uh he's he he's not really because he's
politically conservative and he likes
the american flag and so he's not he's a
white he's a neo-nazi base he's a white
supremacist
doesn't look like one but according to
them he is one so the proud boys were
having some march or rally or something
and they they ripped a blm sign off
or a flag off of a church shouldn't do
that that's a crime
can't steal people's property very bad
thing to do
then they burned the blm flag
this is being investigated as a hate
crime how many
to put this in perspective how many
american flags do you think were ripped
off of buildings during the blm riots
and the antifa riots over the summer
how many american flags do you think
were stolen from people maybe seven
i think a good number and the reason i
say this is because blm and antifa were
burning buildings down
in this summer so i suspect maybe there
was an american flag somewhere around
there
no big deal actually when blm and antifa
burned down
buildings that is completely defended
by the establishment but when these guys
get get a little rowdy they take the
flag they shouldn't have taken the flag
then they burn that that is being
investigated as a hate crime
now i think it's wrong to steal i don't
think we should steal people's flags
however if you go out and buy your own
blm flag
and then douse it in gasoline and set it
on fire that is a good thing
because blm is a marxist organization
that hates this country
it is an evil organization and
absolutely it should not be tolerated
in a civilized society it is explicitly
marxist
and it comes out it explicitly says it
wants to destroy
the nuclear family what that has to do
with uh
racial justice i'm not quite sure
antario comes out and he says the
burning of this banner wasn't about race
religion or political ideology it was
about a racist movement that has
terrorized the citizens of this country
blm
i will not stand by and watch them burn
another city now he was he was being a
little
loose with his language here i agree it
wasn't about race mr
torrio is the same race as as the people
of blm putatively are right it's
it's uh he's a black guy black and
hispanic wasn't about religion in a way
it is about religion right because
the conservatives tend to be christian
and blm is marxist
therefore materialist atheistic and it
is about political ideology blm
is not a race it's not a racial movement
primarily it's a
it's a political and ideological
movement
but this is a hierarchy
you can burn if you if you burn the
american flag you will hear people on
the left and
sort of squishies on the right tell you
that's wonderful oh it's so it's so
important
thomas jefferson one he wrote the
declaration so you can burn the flag
it's a great i'll defend to the death
you're right to burn the flag
the minute someone burns a rainbow flag
someone burns a blm flag someone
probably even burns an antifa flag
all of a sudden you're going to make a
federal case out of it
it's all about overthrowing the old
standards all about smashing the
patriarchy
there was a gal
who this video went viral
i don't know how i don't know why
i don't think it is being facetious i
don't think it's irony or satire
i think this is the new standard i can't
even describe it take a listen
well i have this thing call it a little
quirk if you will i have hair
in my armpit i have it there for a few
reasons one
lazy two the patriarchy and three
your response to them tells me
everything i need to know about you
okay and for those who just listened to
that and didn't see it on the internet
this girl has shaved about two-thirds of
her head and then she has a lot of hair
on the back of her head and she's got
these thick mutton chops and
has armpit hair and you know is uh
has has made some interesting fashion
choices
she would appear to be on the left
i don't think she's right-wing i think
this is her standard
smash the patriarchy and what does that
really get to it gets to this left-wing
view of the country
that is totally full of resentment
everything in the past is bad every
tradition
is bad and it is oppressive and it stops
us from being liberated
right and this is you see this with all
of these stories with
the the way they want to upend the on
the life they want to upend the economy
the way they want to
institute these racist policies on the
vaccine the way that they
want to reorder our political system
the way they want to reorder all of
these things it's because the past is
bad
and the new system is going to be
liberating and much better
now let's go along with that for a
second let's say seriously
i don't obviously don't believe anything
she said but let's say that all those
things are true
if that is liberation
i don't want it
does that girl seem like she's doing
well
it's not even just that girl she's an
extreme example when you go
to your thanksgiving holiday and your
sort of blue-haired feminist
cousin-in-law or something comes up to
you and and
starts yelling at you about liberation
and your politics and
trump or whatever you know
when you talk to these people do they
really seem like they've figured it out
like they're in a good place like
they're happy they're thriving they're
flourishing
no i don't think so that is not the look
of a stable grounded centered person
and yet there are a great many people
who are
who don't look or sound or shriek like
that
who nevertheless believe those kinds of
arguments
you know look they'll get married
they'll settle down they'll basically
live by the kind of conventional rules
and yet they will still buy into this
ridiculous notion
that the past and traditions are all
terrible and oppressive and
you know leftism is really liberating
they'll buy into it they're being
inundated with it by the public health
establishment by the mainstream media by
the entertainment media
by higher education lower education big
tech everything
so they buy into it it's completely
but they buy into it if the country has
come that
far apart how are we supposed to come
back together
when i was at tpusa over the weekend i
did charlie kirk's podcast
which should be coming out sometime this
week and one topic he brought up is the
idea of a national divorce
that we no longer have anything in
common
with anything whatsoever you know
america does not
you know most people speak english but
it's not
the only language that people speak in
america uh so we don't have that we
don't have a common
religion it was always christianity
broadly but they were all the little
intersection
or intersectional uh all these
denominational battles as you know
between certainly the protestants and
the catholics and within the protestants
so there's kind of more broad
tolerant understanding of religion in
terms of race we've
always i mean obviously a lot of white
people came in early on
but there always were mixed races in
america
you had indians brought in from the
earliest days
into alliances with the pilgrims you had
african slaves brought over
you then had free africans who were in
some ways integrated into the society
and in some ways kept out of the society
you had immigrants coming in from all
over europe then later on you had
immigrants from asia and so
you've always had those quite you don't
have a common race really in america
you don't have a lot of common things
and yet
if you're all patriots if you all love
your country
if you can all broadly agree not even on
what your country stands for necessarily
you know you need to get to some of that
but even just if you can all agree your
country is
good and you like it and you want it to
succeed and continue if you can agree on
that you can have a country
but we can't agree on that now i think
that the flag
issue the flag maybe hypocrisy maybe
hierarchy shows you this
the left is is desecrating disrespecting
in some cases outright burning the
american flag
right now that is
a level of extremism we had not seen in
this country for a long time what the
left would say is
look i defend the right to burn the flag
but it's a condemnable act rbg said this
she said i think it's foolish and stupid
and incoherent
to burn the flag now you've got people
cheering on colin kaepernick
now you've got people pointing to the
flag as basically just a symbol of the
republican party or conservatives or
mega or trump
and that's true that's basically what
it's become the left has other flags
blm the rainbow flag the antifa flag
right they've got all these other
symbols for them
if you don't have even that common
grounding it's like any divorce is an
apt metaphor i think
because let's say you and your wife are
fighting if you're trying to fix your
marriage you're not going to fix your
marriage by saying i was right about
this and you didn't get this right and
you did this to me and i did this to you
and figure out exactly who was right
the way you're going to fix your
marriage is you have to love one another
that's the first part of it
and right now it would seem the left
does not love
the conservatives and frankly
conservatives aren't feeling
particularly warm about
leftists at this point because of all
the madness that you see going on
and all the uh castigating us as bitter
clinging bigots and fools and nazis and
all that sort of thing
well right now according to rasmussen 56
of americans see joe biden
as the legitimately elected president
only 56
actually might be as low as 52 depending
on how you word the question
that is a shocking whatever you think
about the election just that number is
shocking
only 56 percent of americans
can even agree and look i think it's the
left's fault i think they
undertook such outrageous irregularities
in the election in some places they
actually did cheat and and because of
that no one has
faith in the process anymore how do you
have a country after that
well as the country sort falls apart
then it becomes a raw power grab
and you're going to see much stronger
claims for hierarchy
and the ideological hierarchy has
already kicked into effect
i i hope we can stay on the air i'm
michael knowless the michael knowles
show
see you tomorrow
the michael knoll show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel valdovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matte wall show it's not just another
show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about
hope you'll give it a listen